do you believe it's better that
characters drive plot or is it better to
have plot decide what the characters do
oh absolutely character
like character comes first um
their
world
is
needs to be challenged and the like you
know it has to be an organ like if the
plot if the characters are going through
a movie
just
to service the plot basically
then i mean i guess that's fine if it's
just a i don't know like a transformers
or something like that where you know
like what you're getting into but like
for the
this the cinema
side of it i guess
yeah like you know you want and in
writing and edit editing in particular i
mean all that stuff like comes back into
play where you know if the if you feel
like the
characters are doing things in service
of the plot for the plot to like develop
you know the audience feels that
and um
and so then they they kind of get pulled
out a little bit they might still like
they might give you a couple of shots
you know you may get like
like a couple of chances where like
maybe the audience doesn't know exactly
and so they go along because there's one
one little like shady plot point that
you kind of have to get through to get
everything else to happen right or you
need to cut a scene out and so now it
gets a little
uh finicky but if it happens too much
like that's where i think you know you
kind of lose interest in the movie um
kind of deflates by the end
have you ever been attracted to a film
because of the character but not the
plot but it held your attention so much
that you were able to finish it and you
can name it as one of the films that you
love or at least like
yeah of course i mean i just watched
uh white lotus for instance which was
like that whole series is basically a
character like study to me and it's not
really plot driven at all it's not
obviously not a movie but just because i
just finished it um where i was
absolutely engaged throughout the entire
series because of those characters and
who they were um
so i think that that's absolutely part
of and especially you know sometimes
it's the casting sometimes sometimes
it's the writing it just depends but of
course absolutely i think that can
happen and i think that those films also
tend to you tend to think of them as
character studies where they don't have
that much plot
in them but i
i feel like that's not entirely true
they just may be disguised so well by
the character and the writing that you
don't recognize that it is that there's
still plot that it's that's moving
through that story
um and that's an important thing to
remember as a writer and edited
in particular
oh interesting okay so you're lumping
those two together writer and editor and
they go hand in hand
yeah and i think maybe that's just
because of um they don't always go hand
in hand but
in my experience like the last four or
five years have been primarily in
documentaries
uh
but before that it was almost an
exclusively
narrative for me
and
what i have found
to be
similar even from narrative to to
documentaries but in particular
documentaries is that you're really
writing the story as an editor a lot of
times and uh
and it's not that dissimilar from trying
to write a script
like often like i mean you still have to
hit your plot beats you still have to
figure out where
uh reversals can happen and what can
change the direction of the film to give
it some new life when it gets stale like
i mean all that stuff still applies
in a documentary that would as if you're
writing a script from you know from page
one
what character do you love in white
lotus
i love the hotel manager i think he's a
fascinating fascinating character
to watch what was it about him
like the color of his like personality
um i think all the characters are really
really great in that show because
they both none of them are are good or
bad like i mean they are and they aren't
they're they're so gray and
and like sort of relatable but also like
you kind of hate them
and
it's just a fascinating uh like kind of
place to be as an audience because
you're not really sure
what you want even to happen you just
like seeing
their who they all are
and then what happens when they get in
the same room together and like that
explosion is just i don't know i think
that that's fantastic uh writing
do you always have to love a character
to be invested no you can you can
actually hate the character or or
intensely dislike them i think that um
well i mean you know uh
like breaking bad is a great example i
mean like a lot of a lot of stuff right
now i think is trying to toy with a
that
that line of can we
can we have a just like a despicable
um character that maybe
gives the audience a carrot of hope that
they might grow or be better and then
you know maybe they do maybe they don't
but that's like
there's like something that that
attracts you
to wanting to find that out succession
is another one um
for me that
you know
it's like obviously all these people are
terrible
but they're also
uh
fascinating to see ex like you know
collide and
what this like where that story might
even go um
the acting of course like makes a big
difference in that too i think sometimes
to be between whether the audience can
can sympathize even at all with somebody
so despicable i mean that's that's i
think really where the casting
can kind of take something to another
level too
if you were to make another sci-fi film
would it be about the characters or
would it be about the sci-fi world
um
well
i think that
if you asked me that
um
you know 10 years ago i probably would
have been more interested in the world
part of it
um i i think now
i am more interested in
how the world can inform
the story you want to tell with a
character uh but this but the character
really still needs to happen kind of
first i mean
they the character that you
have
needs to fit
within the world to make a um
like for a reason i mean everything
everything has to be somewhat calculated
in that in that sense but the character
is still going to take you through that
story and it's really the world is
really only there to help either say
something about the world we live in
today or about the character and what
their struggle is that's relatable to us
today even though it might be alien in
the context of what you're seeing
and so i think just
you know
i think the character
side of things always wins out in the
end over
over um world building i mean like
world building is tough though too uh to
do
and um i've had a couple of
cracks at it and i'm still working
through
uh what's the best way to
to get all this information in without
stopping you know it or like because
people in general are don't care about
the world building as much as a
filmmaker does you know what i mean like
they just want to know if the story is
going to captivate them
and um take them on an emotional journey
or a ride in some way shape or form
and uh you know but the world building
is like kind of the nitty-gritty things
that we get excited about sometimes just
because
it may be what provoked the thought of
even you know diving into a story
somewhere along that line so i think
it's just about trying to find the
balance uh because you can't really do
one or the other i mean i think they
always they kind of it's like you get
here with the world but then you get
here with the character in a sci-fi
um sense like it's a i think they have
to inform each other um but my my vote
would always go like i think now in
particular to the character and that
being uh
the source of the journey that you're
really going on
what questions are you asking yourself
when you're creating characters i think
the the one that i'm asking myself most
is
how
um
like you know
sort of like especially with the amount
of content that's out right now or is
coming out constantly i think
you know
it's hard to kind of reinvent the wheel
right but
uh and and you know i may be a little
bit doubtful uh to some extent about
about what i'm working on at the moment
because i'm not really sure where it's
going just yet but i'm constantly asking
myself is this good enough and i always
almost always think no
and it's like a little bit of a
you know because i as i'm striving for
something
that i know i want to hit and so i'm
like just really trying to hold myself
accountable to can
have i seen this character or storyline
before like you know is there a way i
can make their introduction
uh
more uh more appealing in a sense of
like is that interesting is it something
new does it tell me who they really are
can i do this without dialogue all those
types of things i think is really more
where my head is at right now versus
then
like
just like keeping it that's that's
simple i guess with the
with um
you know with what am i asking about the
character it's a little bit like what
can't i do with this character and where
do i want them to go i mean i think i'm
a little bit more of an organic
like writer in that sense
because as even though i mentioned
character is the most important thing
i still have to work out everything else
for that character to be valuable too
you know what i mean like and then i i
can kind of reverse engineer
and then
if i if that takes me down a different
direction i follow it but i'm not you
know it's a it's it's a constant process
of of uh
rewriting and rethinking and
and until you kind of get to the end and
again it's like at a certain point i
guess you have to just
believe that it's going to all work
too to go into production but that's
where i hope to go next uh you know i
want to
get uh i've been doing docs for
uh the last like four or five years and
and i'm really itching to kind of do a
narrative again so i'm in the middle of
this struggle right now
and of course
uh you know we're just coming out of uh
of a you know just an insane year um
where everything sort of feels like it's
changed
and that's a struggle because this idea
that i was working on like kind of like
was something that
you know was older but i'm you know i'm
even asking myself well is it is it
worthy of a of us being a story now
given the the way it's almost like you
know we had like a 9 11 moment where
there was you know
like you just know that that the
industry has changed audiences have
changed what they want to see has
changed and i have to
remind myself that that all that does
matter is at the end of the day too
because
you know you want to make this movie and
then the next one also and
if you um
and i i want to take into account that
audience and who they are and
and what they want to see too
do you become obsessive
with certain characters that you've
written that you've created no i don't
think so i um
i am obsessive in the in the sense of uh
like like it's hard for me to not think
about what i'm working on sometimes
even like if i'm like right before bed
um
like say i want to turn my brain off but
it just keeps going and going going like
that kind of stuff but i'm not obsessive
um
you know nothing i think as an editor
you've just kind of learned that like
you know everything can get cut it may
not be your decision but somebody can
cut something that you love
and uh
you have to do it maybe or whatever you
know what i mean like that's just part
of the process like it's never going to
stay
the same on the page that it does by the
end
really and
knowing that
uh i think just helps me kind of
deal with like that kind of stuff like
oh my god this isn't good enough like oh
like you know what let me combine these
two characters into one because i don't
know why i have two like they're like
those even though
maybe if you know when i was younger and
i was less experienced with so many
different aspects of the process i may
have been like like well yeah but
they're but we're going to cast them and
then it's going to be it's going to work
you know i i think right now it's like
the script has to sell itself
too in order for it to get made so i'm
kind of way more in the the camp these
days of
of like really don't be precious too
much with certain things
notes
are valuable
and um
one of the best pieces of advice that i
ever got
uh was from another director
who uh basically told me
that
whatever the note is more than more than
likely it's actually like just doing
that isn't going to solve anything it
may get you to the next point in that
process
but really
most people don't know how to really
give
you
like a really critical note that's
valuable sometimes it's up to you as a
receiver of those notes to figure out
what they actually mean
and then make those changes and that's
that's that's um
something that has proven to be
invaluable for me like since since he
basically gave me that that advice
because every time i ever get a note
it's like what does that actually mean
because if i do the notes i it's it's
almost never like really like i
so there's one time actually
where i got a bunch of notes
uh did them all they they liked it and
i hated it with a passion
and
and i asked uh like to go into like a
hole for a weekend
uh to like try to figure out how to fix
the notes but not do these notes exactly
like i knew that there was something
wrong but i hadn't cros it hadn't like i
hadn't figured out what it was
and um
and so i went in
down down this hole and basically
uh all these notes were about uh shaving
this character down
uh like they didn't like her let's say
and uh what i ended up doing
is putting all those things back in that
i shaved that they got addressed and cut
out this character's introduction
and
apparently that like and i actually
thought it was better too but it took a
lot of
what does that mean why are they why are
all these no because i don't not like
this character but the introduction was
off-putting enough that
uh that if i just introduced her in the
next scene
it changed everything and then all the
other notes went away
and that was that's so that's a really
good example of at least as an editor
but i know that happens in writing and
all
aspects of of the filmmaking process
where taking the uh note that you're
given and and trying to to figure out
what exactly is the root of of that
is um i think really where your work can
can be
can uh can really uh excel and you can
still play in the game basically
uh because you're you're solving
everything
and making it better and so everybody
wins